[Music]
what's up reject nation it's John
Humphrey here
you can't make fun of yourself I have to
make funny oh I'm sorry
it's way this works do we go dynamic
what's up reject nation I'm John
Humphrey alright I'm Greg album and
today were gonna do a very special
patron video request shouts out to the
man Gregory Bullock Gregory Bullock is a
lot of things but one of those things he
is a singer with a very velvety set of
pipes and he made this song called today
in history and we're gonna react to it
but before we do that shouts out to
everyone who's joined us over on the
patreon just because this is a patron
video request that has gone on the
youtubes right we gotta let the people
know that what it is John's birthday I
was gonna get to that no were you gonna
totally skip that no I was gonna get
back to that but now the surprise party
they're taking two minutes to get to the
anyway come check us out hey Tom I got
full like TV show reactions QAS music
videos stuff a whole lot of fun people
we make for live music yeah anyway come
over there if you want to see some TV
show reaction stream Long's to shows
like my hero academia Full Metal
Alchemist Brotherhood attack on Titan
maybe one punch man we'll come back
sometime did all honey of he'll how
sweet guy Gotham we got Cobra Kai season
two supernatural and we've also got TV
show reaction highlights with footage
included for Full Metal Alchemist
Brotherhood attack on Titan supernatural
and my hero academia and if you want the
one punch man those are there as well
anyway as I did not reveal to the people
Greg made a song called today in history
not parentheses Gregory bullet made song
for us and it's called John's bday is
for us for us I'm sure you'll be
involved in the song I get the sense
that this is not
into it but it means the world to me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Wow I think the outro part is my
favorite for some reason because I like
to imagine that each and every of
Gregory Bullock's voices that
contributed to this song is each its own
separate cognizant entity and they were
all commenting on it at the same time
cuz whimsy is the thing I'm a fan of but
thanks man he's really lovely just
grinned throughout the whole thing David
Gandy sent one over two did roll that
quit roll that beautiful bean footage
[Music]
happy birthday John thank you also to
David Gandy I feel bad because I already
saw that on Greg's phone so I had a
reaction in the wild and we didn't catch
it and I'm really sorry about that but
this is I mean you've made me a song for
my birthday now Greg has made me Greg
Bullock I'm sorry on that song you read
condit gone channeling stricken now
there's a wrap up called I'm like so
flattered I want to put a playlist
together just like listen to it
throughout my birthday cuz the beautiful
thing about this video is that it's
gonna be up on YouTube and then you can
just kind of click on it whenever and
then any day could be my birthday it's
true you know cuz we're not even
recording this on my actual birthday
look John I'm gonna make this about me
and I'm so going to this is better than
the one he made me for my birthday
whoa whoa whoa I mean I now I'm pissed
you're next I like to think that Greg
Bullock is a lot like The Killers you
know how the killers make a song every
year for our Lord and Savior Jesus
Christ's birthday I think he's gonna do
that for the both of us every time each
of us has a birthday so coming September
I'm gonna be sweating because I'm gonna
be like bull [ __ ] what's Greg gonna come
up with this time is he gonna come up
with like a 3 verse song is there gonna
be like a whole stylistic change up is
he gonna throw in instruments is he
gonna find a whole new way to harness
the power of a cappella like I don't
like the killers you don't own it all I
like that one song yeah these things
that I've done I want to know what
everybody thought right before you
filled in the blank because I feel like
that's a pretty wide margin
and the killer that one zone yeah yeah
the killer is that one how was your
birthday John it was a nice birthday I'm
not overly good at celebrating it like a
normal person but I did a little bit
better this year and it's a normal
person's birthday I don't know I feel
like it's my birthday oh my god so draw
I don't know I always get kind of
reflective around my birthdays or
anything that signifies the passage of
time 29 sit down in Journal but like I
don't know I mean you got to think about
these things right every birthday and
every new year is a checkpoint of
quantifiable time for you to go how am i
doing on this journey you know life just
divides it up for you with handy little
place markers and luckily for me my
birthday is like smack dab in the middle
of the years so it's a pretty even
6-month cycle of room okay let's see
where I've been over this amount of time
but it was a nice man who's a nice
birthday a lot of love which I
appreciate I mean you've got me some
followers on the internet which is
that's what I do from young man you're
good at that you're there 10 to 20
followers and then I'm like oh crap but
I got to come up with good stuff to post
now cuz I'm really bad at using social
media it's a good thing you're assigned
as the social media guy for the real
region it's different in that regard
although our social media could be a lot
better I'm not gonna lie I'm gonna go on
the record and say I could do a much
better job at that it's when I have more
arms and another brain I'll get ya when
I can do it like a man in black or like
that octopus from that one movie is
making this pseudo Monsters Inc so
making the sushi yeah which seems really
messed up when you think about it like
that an octopus would be making sushi I
never thought about that now that is
true mm-hmm unless it's like cruelty
free but but would that octopus care cuz
that octopus in and of himself is a
monster I mean lives in the monster
community so maybe part of the reason
he's there is because he's such a
monster you okay I'll officially knocked
let's bring me an octopus I'm a cannibal
whatever anyway Thank You Gregory
Bullock
making this song for me and bringing
your creativity in such a personal and
creative it's redundant to say creative
way but yeah I mean I really appreciate
the ways in which you help us to feel
special on these little milestones of
life and now I have one of my very own
and I no longer resent you because for
the longest time I resented the [ __ ] out
of you man I was like why does everyone
love Greg and hate John and never
acknowledge my exit
I'm the star of a lot of the exact
opposite situation you haven't seen all
the video have you seen those videos
where people pretend you're invisible me
personally now not you people don't
pretend you're in this no idea it's a
pill for any challenge yeah yeah I've
been a part of so many of those and so
it's just nice to well when the camera's
not rolling that's as humorous for me
that's I know but like it's really
convincing you get sad it's me I don't
know which is real anymore and it's
really bothering me because you know
I'll wake up in a cold sweat and feel
like is this the reality you know and
then it's like that show with Jason
Isaacs that was on network television
for a little while where it was like
which one is he really is he the one
where he wakes up or is when he goes to
sleep and he's dreaming is that the real
world
it's a lot like that but with us in this
office so it's way more contained much
better series because we hit there yeah
we're 10 minutes now we can end this
[Music]
Gregory Bullock much love to you I
really appreciate you in Italy carry
this video yeah man I don't count you
guys I'm gonna start bringing a hell of
guests on we're gonna do this John's
taken over 2019 anyway yeah so if you
guys have any feelings about this video
please weigh in in the comments and I'm
reading that guy no no say something
genial tonight say something I'm giving
up on you and this video is copyright
claim now so we really gotta wrap this
thing up go visit our patreon click the
notification bell and subscribe and
don't forget to hit that like button cuz
that's the thing that apparently helps
the most now and we'll see you on the
next one be well party people
and as always Cheers that it's from
patriarchy all the John things